bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans
savouregarde ce soir le pari fou d'un
écrivain français en Iran et cet
écrivain c'est vous François Henri des
érable bonsoir et merci d'être notre
grand témoin ce soir vous publiez
l'usure d'un monde chez Gallimard une
traversée passionnante de l'Iran le pays
des Mollat où vous avez passé 40 jours
fin 2022 en pleine révolte populaire et
au plus fort de la répression du régime
après la mort de Massa aminis c'est un
témoignage absolument inédit et c'est
aussi un grand resty littéraire dont on
va parler tout à l'heure dans la
deuxième partie mais on commence ce soir
avec la LPM la loi de programmation
militaire depuis la guerre en Ukraine la
France mesure l'urgence de ce réarmer
413 milliards d'euros sur sept ans le
budget de la défense fait un immense
beau en avant et il est discuté en ce
moment même à l'Assemblée alors 413
milliards exactement pourquoi faire
quelle vision stratégique c'est notre
grand débat ce soir dans un instant avec
nos invités avant de retrouver à 20h15
les affranchis pour leur parti pris et
puis dans Bourbon Express ce soir la
bataille du 8 juin dans les mes cycles
sur les retraites qui se préparent voilà
pour le menu vous me suivez François
Henri desseirables ça vous regarde c'est
parti
[Musique]
des efforts à proportion des dangers
gros plan donc ce soir sur la loi de
programmation militaire c'est le cadre
budgétaire qui engage les
investissements de la France dans la
défense et sur les années sur les 7
années à venir trois députés l'examine
de très très près cette LPM bonsoir Loïc
kervant et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes députés horizon du Cher horizon le
groupe d'Edouard Philippe membre de la
majorité présidentielle bonsoir
Jean-Louis Thiriot et bienvenue vous
êtes député des républicains de
Seine-et-Marne et bonsoir anapick
bonsoir député socialiste de la Manche
tous les trois vous êtes membre de la
commission de la défense et vous
messieurs vous en êtes même les deux vis
président enfin bonsoir général bonsoir
général Jérôme pélestrondi rédacteur en
chef de la revue défense nationale alors
évidemment François en désirable la
défense c'est pas votre terrain de jeu
mais vous revenez d'Iran et votre regard
nous intéresse parce que le monde est de
plus en plus menaçant et donc n'hésitez
pas à intervenir n'hésitez pas même à
interroger nos invités on commence comme
chaque soir par planter le décor 413
milliards d'euros je le disais c'est
énorme pourquoi faire les grands
gagnants les perdants aussi dans ce
budget défense il a de 100 secondes
c'est le défi de Blacko top chrono c'est
parti
voir les dépenses militaires les
dépenses militaires de l'Europe c'est
cette ligne orange vous voyez l'Europe
pensait pouvoir commercer en paix dans
un monde mondialisé où tout se passerait
bien sans se rendre compte que les
dépenses militaires du reste du monde
elles va augmenter le reste du monde se
prépare à la guerre même les États-Unis
vous voyez depuis 2016 on commençait à
faire augmenter leur budget donc pour
nous c'est surtout de une histoire de
combler le retard aussi bien pour la
France que pour l'Europe alors que faire
de ces 400 milliards donc on va parler
un peu de matériel mais quel est le
premier poste de défense pour la défense
bah c'est comme pour beaucoup les
soldats reprises le la pardon la masse
salariale voilà tout simplement pour
avoir des bons soldats il faut pouvoir
bien les payer et donc c'est un problème
en ce moment notamment puisque il y a la
fidélisation on appelle ça des soldats
pose un problème un tiers de ce confort
mais finit par quitter l'armée sans
servir sous les drapeaux donc l'autre
poste de défense important et qui est
spécifique à la France pour ça que je
vais mal avancer la dissuasion nucléaire
la France est le seul pays de l'Union
européenne qui a une bombe nucléaire si
on veut rester garder ce statut ça veut
dire plus de 50 milliards de dépenses
sur 7 ans peut-être quelque chose dont
vous débattrez ce soir alors pour lancer
ces engins bien sûr il faut d'autres
dépenses donc par exemple un sous-marin
lanceur d'engins un celui de la
troisième génération la construction de
la commencer voyez à la fin de l'année
autre monstre d'acier qui fera la fierté
de l'armée française le pong je sais pas
si vous connaissez le Pang moi je sais
parce que j'ai travaillé moi j'ai
découvert le pancré ça c'est le
porte-avion nouvelle génération donc il
devrait permettre à la France de
transporter des centaines d'avions de
chasse un peu partout sur le monde et
donc d'intervenir dans des zones qui
l'intéressent par exemple la fameuse
zone Indo-Pacifique auquel est attaché
le président Macron mais au-delà donc de
ces grosses dépenses parfois de prestige
il y a aussi un souci de moderniser
l'armée donc j'ai pris l'exemple des
drones on a vu pendant la guerre en
Ukraine à quel point c'était important
sur le champ de bataille mais dans
d'autres domaines aussi de la guerre de
l'espace à surveillance par le satellite
donc les renseignements quelque chose
qui va être très développé et notamment
les domaines cyber les attaques qui sont
sur les réseau ou les appareils de
guerre connectés l'un à l'autre alors
bien sûr la question qu'on se pose
maintenant qu'on a fait un tour rapide
vous savez ce que cette loi va être
adoptée il y a quand même des
oppositions à l'Assemblée pourquoi tant
d'argent pour l'armée Fabien Roussel par
exemple lui il n'est pas tout à fait
d'accord en écoute ils sont en train de
mettre le pays à feu et à 100 pour 12
milliards d'euros de déficits dans notre
système de retraite attention en 2030 là
pour 12 milliards d'euros ils mettent le
pays à feu et à 100 et on va faire
passer le budget des armées de 32
milliards par an à 69 milliards d'euros
par an je dis c'est trop que le budget
augmente oui à ce niveau là non donc la
gauche n'est pas très chaude mais le
gouvernement ne s'inquiète pas trop
parce que du côté des républicains
certes il y a des critiques et je pense
que Jean-Louis Thériault Thieriot les
exprimer mais est-ce qu'on va voter pour
la loi pas sûr mais en tout cas on
l'écoute je pense qu'on peut d'ores et
déjà dire qu'il est exclu que nous
votions contre parce que le parti du
nain de Gaulle ne vote pas
contre une loi de programmation
militaire qui augmente de 30% les
budgets consacrés aux armées j'espère
que vous n'avez pas changé d'avis
monsieur Thiriau parce que voilà c'est
facile donc évidemment sur le plan
politique ça ne pose pas vraiment de
problème la loi de programmation
militaire devrait être adoptée mais ça
n'empêche pas d'être mener un débat sur
cette question parce que c'est un sujet
très important pour le pays évidemment
et on comprend pourquoi dans ce monde de
plus en plus menaçant Loïc Kervran le
ministre Sébastien Lecornu parle de
politique de rupture d'expression est
justifiée c'est le plus gros budget
jamais consacré à la défense depuis les
années 60 c'est c'est le retour de la de
la guerre froide on se on se réarme on
renucléarise c'est la prise de
conscience d'abord que le monde autour
de nous il est dur il est très agressif
avec la France et puis à ça est venu se
rajouter l'Ukraine il faut pas évaluer
la loi de programmation militaire
seulement à l'aune de ce qui s'est passé
en Ukraine mais c'est un élément
supplémentaire qui justifie qu'on ait
besoin avant que la loi de programmation
militaire qui est en cours précédente se
terminer de remettre de revenir au
travail là-dessus et donc
du produit intérieur brut ce budget
c'est ce que nous demandait autant donc
en même temps on n'est pas non plus on
rattrape un peu des années de vachement
puisque finalement ça dépend avant tout
du produit intérieur brut et de son
évolution et par exemple au moment du
covid quand le produit intérieur bu au
fondé on avait dépassé ce taux de 2%.
donc les chiffres absolus ils sont quand
même importants on peut retenir que en
2017 on avait à peu près 32 milliards de
budget chaque année pour la défense à la
fin de la loi de programmation militaire
si elle est adoptée on sera à 70 alors
pour comprendre parce que c'est
compliqué loi de programmation limitaire
et puis je vous passe la parole ça nous
engage ou ça nous engage pas c'est sur
sept ans après tout en 2027 Emmanuel
Macron ne sera plus président donc celui
qui lui succédera pourra défaire tout ça
ou pas oui ça donne en fait un cap ça
permet de programmer des investissements
qui dans nos armées vous voyez avec les
matériels le ping le porte-avion
nucléaire nouvelle génération etc nous
avons besoin de temps parce que ce sont
des investissements qui se déroulent sur
plusieurs années ensuite il faut que
cette programmation elle soit confirmée
par les lois de finances annuelles c'est
ce qui a été le cas depuis 2017 puisque
la loi de programmation militaire depuis
2017 elle est exécutée à l'euro près
même elle est sur exécutée comme on dit
c'est à dire qu'on a dépensé même plus
que ce qu'on avait fait une trajectoire
fiable quel que soit les dirigeants et
les élus Jean-Louis chiot un saut
capacités voilà ce que disent les
acteurs les experts et notamment les
militaires c'est ce qu'il réclamait ça
veut dire quoi déjà un saut capacitaire
et est-ce qu'on y est
alors je crois qu'il faut un peu
replacer les choses dans leur contexte
on n'est pas dans un effort inouï
jusqu'en 89 et jusqu'à la fin de la
guerre froide on était à 3% du PIB
aujourd'hui on est à 2% enfin on va
arriver à 2% peu importe les virgules
c'est un effort c'est pas un effort
exceptionnel la vraie rupture elle est
pas maintenant je crois que la vraie
rupture elle a eu lieu en 2017 quand le
président de la République a décidé de
mettre un terme à ce qui avait été
l'abandon de l'effort de défense au nom
des dividendes de la paix où on était
tombé 1,4 % sous capacités objectivement
non nous avions fait un rapport sur le
combat de haute intensité en février
2022 c'est-à-dire la guerre massive
l'engagement majeur où nous avions dit
il y a des trous capacitaires
importantes il y a des matériels qui
manquent des fonctions qui ne sont plus
assurés on avait notamment beaucoup
parlé des feux dans la profondeur et
finalement ce qu'on avait analysé le
rôle très important des sésame nous
l'avions dit à l'époque nous avions du
génie nous avions évoqué ces trous et
bien dans les faits nous ont prouvé que
nous n'avions pas tort aujourd'hui ce
que cette loi de programmation militaire
permet c'est de retrouver de la
cohérence retrouver de la cohérence et
qu'aujourd'hui nous avions une logique
de parc nous avons des chars nous avons
des hélicoptères nous avons des avions
mais nous avons parfois des chars qui ne
roulent pas des hélicoptères qui ne
veulent pas et des chars qui sont
bloqués parce que
soutient n'est pas là donc l'idée c'est
vraiment d'avoir un outil de défense le
plus cohérent possible pour que quand on
engage les hommes on puisse vraiment les
avoir efficacement sur le terrain c'est
pas une rupture c'est pas un saut mais
c'est une amélioration globale
importante le gros du budget analyse
quand même quand on regarde il est
aspiré par la dissuasion nucléaire 60%
va aller à la modernisation des armes
les têtes nucléaires mais aussi les
missiles et porteurs comme les rafales
les sous-marins en tout cas c'est ce que
j'ai pu lire vous êtes là pour me
corriger est-ce que on y va marche
forcée cette dissuasion du clair c'est
notre doctrine mais on doit l'assumer
davantage aujourd'hui la dissuasion
nucléaire effectivement un pilier de la
défense française on ne peut pas le nier
et il est important de continuer
l'investissement dans cette dissuasion
nucléaire nous savons aujourd'hui que
effectivement ça nous place dans une
position particulière est-ce que nous
devons miser uniquement sur la
dissuasion nucléaire non évidemment je
crois que ça vient d'être dit il y avait
une nécessité à réparer mais je ne vais
pas faire une bataille de chiffres ici
mais je dirais que la trajectoire
financière n'est effectivement n'assure
pas un sous capacitaire énorme puisqu'il
y a des enjeux il y avait des enjeux
profonds avec des creux qui nous
empêchaient par exemple une préparation
opérationnelle de nos forces qui soient
à la hauteur que l'on peut attendre nous
avons encore d'exemples très concrets
très concrètement si on n'a pas les
matériels disponibles parce que
effectivement en stock sur le papier il
y a bien des hélicoptères il y a bien
des avions il y a bien des navires mais
qu'en réalité ou des véhicules mais
qu'en réalité trop vieux et bien ils ne
sont soit ils sont employés parce que
comme on en a pas tant que ça et bien on
a une armée d'emploi et bien ils sont
pas disponibles pour l'entraînement soit
effectivement ils sont sur le papier
mais en réalité c'est des matériels dont
on ne peut plus servir donc il y avait à
faire un gros effort aujourd'hui on
investit sur des matériels qui sont très
coûteux et nous avons une armée avec des
compétences incroyables avec on va
encore élargir le champ des compétences
de nos armées la question qui se pose
s'effacent à une nécessité de
massification éventuelle c'est à dire en
cas de conflit de haute intensité et
pour ça il faut une autre jambe pour
parler très concrètement la France si
elle entre en guerre toute seule c'est
pas possible c'est-à-dire concrètement
très concrètement évidemment il faut
reposer sur des alliances et
partenariats et autant on est là pour ça
autant autant évidemment puisque nous
sommes aujourd'hui non seulement dans
l'OTAN mais dans le commandement intégré
et je crois que on voit la nécessité
puisque notre armée elle est très
performante mais sur des petits
effectifs et face à éventuel un évent
agresseur il est bien évident que nous
n'aurions pas la possibilité de
massifier rapidement les forces en
présence en général votre lecture on a
besoin d'avoir un peu la vision
stratégique parce que on a des parts de
milliards on a 10 milliards pour le
porte-avion vont en reparler 60%
d'efforts dans le renseignement ça je
crois que c'est très important 5
milliards pour les drones 49 milliards
pour l'entretien militaire au service de
quelle vision stratégique alors
justement je partage les les trois
positions parce que en fait elle
convergent vers un enjeu vers la
question justement de qu'est-ce que nous
voulons faire avec notre défense et
c'est ce qui fait la différence par
exemple avec l'Allemagne ou la Pologne
la Pologne en réalité et n'a qu'un seul
problème c'est la Russie donc tout son
effort de défense il est tourné vers une
défense terrestre face à l'EST
l'Allemagne est un peu dans le même dans
la même problématique or nous nous
sommes d'abord un des cinq membres
permanents du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies donc avec des
responsabilités il y en a qui dépassent
largement le 1% de la population mondial
que nous représentons avec le fait que
nous avons un des intérêts vitaux qui
vont de l'Indo-Pacifique en passant par
les Antilles et ce qui veut dire aussi
que nos armées doivent répondre à un
spectre de mission extrêmement large
c'est-à-dire qu'il va effectivement de
la défense du on va dire de l'espace
européen et les leçons de l'Ukraine sont
à cet égard extrêmement importantes mais
aussi par rapport par exemple à la
compétition stratégique qu'impose la
Chine dans l'Indo-Pacifique
l'Indopacifique envoyer des forces dans
l'Indo-Pacifique c'est compliqué c'est
loin et c'est effectivement l'un des
objectifs de la prochaine loi de
programmation sinon de pouvoir et bien
renforcer ses capacités mais il faut
effectivement être réaliste d'Emmanuel
Macron est-ce que vous pouvez nous la
décrypter nous ne devons pas faire pour
autant malgré les milliards en plus
pareil avec plus mais nous devons faire
mieux différemment c'est à dire ah mais
ça c'est je dirais que pendant des on a
dû faire à peu près autant avec beaucoup
moins et donc
les chefs militaires ont dû essayer de
trouver des parades pour essayer de avec
des capacités qui ont été fortement
réduits pour certaines supprimer
aujourd'hui nous avons alors je place en
tant que militaire nous avons une
responsabilité à l'égard de la nation de
nos concitoyens que c'est l'argent qui
va être mis à notre disposition soit
particulièrement bien utilisé c'est à
dire que nous avons une responsabilité
pour que ces investissements qui vont
être faits soit les plus efficaces et
répondent en fait à l'objectif politique
qui est qui nous est demandé ce qui est
frappant dans les investissements c'est
les guerres du futur ou celle
d'aujourd'hui les investissements dans
les drôles le cyber le spatial les
satellites de surveillance
hypersophistiqués tout ça c'est ces
prioritaires au fond on doit être
capable de faire la guerre sans la faire
c'est ça ou de téléguider une guerre à
distance comme un peu les Américains le
font aujourd'hui avec l'Ukraine faire
différemment c'est aussi ça c'est
pouvoir travailler dans l'espace se
défendre mais aussi attaquer c'est
pouvoir s'étirer les leçons de l'Ukraine
où on a vu que les drones ont été
utilisés vraiment massivement et ça pose
une interrogation avec la question des
budgets parce que vous avez un drone qui
vaut entre 10 et 20.000 euros pour les
plus perfectionnés qui va lâcher une
munition sur un chat qui lui peut coûter
jusqu'à 10 millions d'euros et donc
c'est cette c'est cette équilibre qu'il
faut trouver et par rapport à ce que
disait général la dépense militaire
française est très efficace nous avons
un budget par exemple qui est inférieur
au Royaume-Uni et pourtant nous avons le
panel complet des responsabilités nous
avons cette responsabilité mondiale nous
avons la dissuasion nous sommes une
armée d'emplois nous avons des
opérations extérieures nous avons plus
d'hommes aussi et de femmes dans nos
armées que le Royaume-Uni et donc c'est
une dépense très efficace et qui en plus
à la fin termine dans les poches
françaises donc la vision stratégique si
on devait la résumer
de cette loi sur 7 ans ce serait quoi
précisément c'est de mettre vraiment le
paquet sur tout ce qui est le cyber
l'espace c'est de s'adapter aussi aux
nouvelles conflictualités le cyber
l'espace et mon collègue Thierry pourra
pour accomplirer c'est la priorité parce
que quand on regarde les effectifs on
voit aussi les augmenter et compris les
effets on y touche pas moi je crois que
ce qui est très important dans ce qu'on
se dit c'est que on augmente pas
finalement la masse le volume et les
effectifs parce que nous avons de
nouvelles conflictualités à traiter
c'est le spatial celle CIBE et ça et les
fonds marins notamment donc on est
obligé de traiter plus de menaces avec
un budget qui reste quand même dans une
épure
on s'arrête parce que je lis 275 000
hommes à l'horizon 2030
mais je crois que sur l'ensemble de la
LPM on gagne 2000 personnes donc c'est
très très peu
on est 1500 je crois oui donc si vous
voulez le volume et le même et aussi
et on demande à l'armée de terre un
effort particulier où il y a un certain
nombre de personnels de l'armée de terre
qui à qui on va se confier des missions
notamment dans le cyber notamment dans
la guerre électronique vont changer de
métier d'une certaine
précisez-nous les choses concrètement
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes engagé sur
le terrain la guerre électronique on le
voit en Ukraine et massive la guerre
électronique s'est détectée les
émissions qui viennent de l'autre côté
pour pouvoir éventuellement guider les
feux d'artillerie aujourd'hui nous avons
déjà ça dans l'armée française mais de
manière relativement embryonnaire on a
vu en Ukraine qu'il fallait avoir ça et
avoir ça massivement et bien ça veut
dire que des artilleurs qui étaient
derrière leur mortier de 120 vont se
retrouver derrière des systèmes de
détection électronique je caricaturer un
peu il faudra faire les brevets faudra
les former mais c'est bien ça l'objectif
donc ça veut dire derrière ça que nous
n'augmentons pas ce qu'on appelle les
forces de mêlée en infanterie cavalerie
parce que on a tout l'environnement
qu'on doit traiter et je crois que là
elle s'il y avait une idée maîtresse de
cette LPM c'est conserver en rendant
plus efficace ce qu'on a et traité les
nouvelles menaces général pressendy
l'armée de terre un peu perdante ou en
tout cas amené à changer mais ce qui est
également aussi quand même le cas pour
pour les autres armées il faut raisonner
globalement ce qui est compliqué
effectivement c'est qu'on doit à la fois
concevoir des systèmes qui vont avoir
une durée de vie de 50 ans c'est le cas
du porte-avion donc quel sera l'horizon
stratégique en
2070 et en même temps dire avoir des
systèmes extrêmement performants mais
pas dans le jetables qui vont servir une
fois sur le champ de bataille ce qui
veut dire que derrière et ça va être un
des enjeux majeurs de cette boîte de
programmation militaire ce n'est pas le
quantitatif que l'on va privilégier mais
le qualitatif et en particulier
justement pour les ressources humaines
et ça c'est quelque chose qui va être un
enjeu majeur parce que si on n'arrive
pas à hausser le niveau qualitatif et
des compétences que ce soit du personnel
militaire ou du personnel civil et bien
on peut avoir un matériel très moderne
mais si on n'arrive pas à vous en parler
ça nous donne un exemple concret ce
fameux porte-avion qui suscite pas mal
de polémiques porte-avions nucléaire
est-ce bien nécessaire c'est le projet
pharaonique de cette loi de
programmation militaire très coûteux et
loin de faire l'unanimité comme nous
l'explique Marco poli
c'est une cathédrale de technologie
d'après le ministre des Armées nom de
code pong voici le futur porte-avion
nouvelle génération de l'armée française
un bâtiment long de 300 mètres
75000 tonnes au total pour un coup
estimé à 10 milliards d'euros un projet
colossal mais indispensable selon
Sébastien Lecornu renoncé à cette
capacité c'est perdre des savoir-faire
unique chez nos marins et assumer un
déclassement durable parmi les autres
nations la construction devrait démarrer
entre 2025 et 2026 sur les chantiers
navals de Saint-Nazaire pour une mise en
service en 2038 c'est-à-dire dans 15 ans
cette base aérienne flottante pourra
transporter jusqu'à 300 avions de chasse
et pourra parcourir 1000 km par jour
objectif remplacer le mythique Charles
de Gaulle comme son prédécesseur se
porte sera à propulsion nucléaire avec
deux mini centrales à bord aujourd'hui
seuls les États-Unis et la France
maîtrise cette technologie c'est
d'autant plus important dans le cas de
la France que la France a des
territoires
ultramarins qui sont dans l'Atlantique
dans le l'océan Indien et dans le
Pacifique ou réside quand même
[Musique]
pratiquement 3 millions de Français donc
c'est pas un sujet anecdotique mais
l'utilité de ce monstre des mers est
aussi questionné à l'heure des missiles
hypersoniques ces armes extrêmement
rapides difficiles à intercepter dans un
conflit majeur le porte-avions pourrait
être alors une cible facile probabilité
de destruction de vulnérabilité du
porte-avion grandit énormément c'est à
la fois un instrument
stratégique qui est désuet qui n'est
plus pertinent qui n'est plus utile
stratégiquement et qui coûte très cher
la France n'est pour pas le seul pays à
faire ce pari la Chine développe elle
aussi un porte-avion à propulsion
nucléaire pour 2027
j'ai envie de sérieux on en a vraiment
besoin de ce nouveau portable Lyon on a
le De Gaulle on nous dit qu'il sera déjà
peut-être général nous dit qu'il sera
déjà peut-être obsolète quand il sera
opérationnel ah non pas au soleil il
faut qu'il puisse suivre les avancées
technologiques
je crois qu'il faut se demander quelle
est la dimension de puissance
stratégique de la France accepter de ne
plus avoir de portavion c'est un des
classements un porte-avion c'est
l'expression des marins mais elle est
juste c'est 75000 tonnes de diplomatie
c'est une dimension symbolique c'est une
dimension de capacité de projection de
puissance ça a une dimension d'influence
et c'est surtout le point dans nos
alliances et le point dans l'Alliance
atlantique aujourd'hui en termes de
puissance navale la France est
particulièrement respectée à cause de
ses porte-avions
de chasse et non pas 300
abandonner le porte-avion alors après il
y a un débat sur le porte-avion et c'est
vrai c'est la question est-ce que ça
deviendra un outil fragile avec les
missiles hypervélote c'est un vrai sujet
ce que je constate et c'est la seule
chose que je peux dire et je ne suis pas
ni marin ni aviateur c'est que un toutes
les pays qui ont des ambitions de
puissance et je pense aux chinois mais
pas seulement eux développent des
portes-avions donc ça veut dire que ça a
une véritable utilité le deuxième
élément que vous diront tous ceux qui
travaillent sur le sujet c'est qu'un
missile il pervélos il va très vite et
si les
perversent les Mac 5 macdis c'est-à-dire
qui veulent à plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres heure et qui est très
difficile à intercepter ce type de
missile qu'il aille vite et qui passe
les défenses c'est possible d'abord on
va faire des progrès mais surtout le
temps même de vol le bateau qui bouge ne
sera pas forcément là où on l'attend et
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut le
rediriger à la fin donc c'est pas sûr du
tout qui puisse le taper enfin le
dernier point c'est que un porte-avion
c'est pas un bateau tout seul dans le
séance c'est une force aéronavale avec
des bâtiments autour dans un rayon d'à
peu près 500 ou 1000 km qui ont un vrai
rôle dans l'interception donc il y a pas
d'armes invincible mais c'est une arme
très importante et essentielle tout à
fait alors je ne suis pas marrant
justement mais je considère que le
porte-avion donc derrière ce qu'on
appelle le groupe aéronaval avec les
bateaux les sous-marins qui qui le
constituent c'est effectivement ce qui
fait la différence c'est à dire que si
nous renonçons bah après le Charles de
Gaulle en disant ça coûte trop cher bon
et bien il faut je vais prendre une
comparaison sportive c'est de nous
acceptons que la France joue en Ligue 2
pour prendre une comparaison de football
et à partir de là de toute façon d'une
part ce sont des capacités que l'on ne
retrouvera plus parce que derrière ce
sont des savoir-faire en gros le
porte-avion français le Charles de
Gaulle il s'appuie sur une expérience
accumulée quand on regarde bien déjà de
près d'un siècle d'aéronavale embarqué
bon par contre effectivement on pourrait
renoncer en disant ça coûte trop cher il
y a d'autres priorités mais
effectivement Thériault
les Chinois
les Indiens
la Turquie vient récemment de mettre un
service un porte aéronef donc il faut
savoir soit on a cette ambition de jouer
le rôle qu'avez-vous le général de
Gaulle sera on accepte de se replier sur
nous-même un applique vous qui êtes de
gauche il y a des clivages on les entend
on a entendu Fabien Roussel c'est pas le
moment c'est pharaonique d'un point de
vue du budget alors c'est un enjeu de
puissance c'est aussi un enjeu d'emploi
on va on va j'espère le construire chez
nous ce porte-avion alors moi d'abord
nous n'avons pas vous le savez très bien
dans la nuit pèse dans cette
inter-groupe chacun des groupes
politiques a une position différente et
en particulier sur les sujets de défense
donc la question est de savoir comment
on trouve cet équilibre justement entre
la haute technologie et la massification
aussi c'est-à-dire le nombre de la
quantité dont on parlait la le choix il
est très clairement fait sur la qualité
et ça a été redit mais il faut quand
même retrouve cet équilibre parce que
nos partenaires attendent de nous aussi
des engagements sur la massification
donc à savoir on en développe un
porte-avion oui et mais comme la dit
jean-lucario il nous faudra autour tout
un tout un tas de navires tout un tas
d'autres choses qui sont absolument
nécessaires pour que cette ce
porte-avion est un intérêt trop cher
c'est pas trop cher et je crois que
héros d'engagement aujourd'hui on a
besoin aussi de cette montée en
technologie et il est quand même le
maritime nous avons une zone économique
exclusive absolument énorme il y a des
enjeux majeurs sur les océans de
protection mais nous avons aussi des
lieux des possibilités de partager et
d'avoir de refaire en sorte de partager
aussi cette défense des zones
économiques exclusives et il y a un
enjeu majeur pour la France de sécuriser
les océans de faire respecter le droit
international sur les océans donc je
crois qu'il y a un à ce porte-avion la
question c'est de savoir comment on fait
pour ne pas miser que sur la technologie
et que nos partenaires nous considèrent
comme fiables sur les autres enjeux
c'est à dire ceux qui consiste à
répondre à la demande et aux besoins des
partenaires et alliés que nous avons non
seulement au sein de l'OTAN mais aussi
pour une défense territoriale européenne
donc pour cette deuxième partie de
demande on est au rendez-vous ou pas
au-delà du porte-avion d'ailleurs il
faut pas assurer le poids du porte-avion
en fait ça coûte 10 milliards mais déjà
il y en a que 5 qui sont dans cette LPM
dans cette loi de programmation
militaire là le reste ça sera pour pour
les Français qui vont payer tout ça
sur 413 et donc bien sûr il y a tout le
reste et notamment moi je pense aux
renseignements où il y a un effort très
important qui est fait parce que le
renseignement pour le coup c'est larmes
du 21e siècle c'est ce qui permet de ne
pas avoir en masse ou si finalement
quelque chose sans fin c'est l'arme qui
vous permet justement d'être voilà
[Musique]
de l'État mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on
investit tellement pourquoi est-ce qu'on
met tellement d'argent dans la défense
parce que si notre pays est envahi si
les hommes et les femmes les Françaises
et les Français sont tués si nos valeurs
elles sont débordées par un adversaire
plus rien de tout le reste n'est
possible tout notre modèle social
l'éducation et cette menace elle est
réelle elle existe déjà dans beaucoup de
champs on a une agressivité économique
qui est extrêmement forte on a une
agressivité cyber qui est très forte etc
et on voit avec l'Ukraine qui a un
retour de la guerre en Europe générale
n'étant pas responsable politique
ce que je constate c'est que avec il a
pas eu que l'Ukraine on le voit depuis
plusieurs années il y a entre les les
démocratures les régimes autoritaires
voire totalitaires la Chine bien sûr la
Russie d'autres il y a un réel recul de
la démocratie dans le monde et donc avec
une espèce de
militaire la Chine construit en quatre
ans l'équivalent de notre marine
nationale et donc nous en France nous
européens nous occidental où il est
défendre ses valeurs les propos de
Vladimir Poutine le 9 mai dire notre
système politique avec ses défauts ces
imperfections et bien il est menacé et
donc la défense reste effectivement une
priorité majeure parce que le jour où on
pourra plus se défendre voilà alors on
apprend très au sérieux cette menace on
va terminer peut-être par un tout petit
aspect c'est la question industrielle
parce que à court terme il y a pas
beaucoup de stocks on l'a bien compris
d'autant qu'on donne une partie et c'est
tant mieux de nos canons Césars aux
Ukrainiens il faut absolument reproduire
et vite est-ce qu'on en a les moyens en
France réindustrialiser notre défense
d'abord on a des entreprises de la
défense qui sont extrêmement
performantes et qui savent faire des
outils de très haute qualité et je dis
simplement que nous avons pour ça
évidemment besoin que de ces entreprises
elles puissent compter sur une
visibilité et permettre effectivement
que conforme des compétences et là il y
a besoin et effectivement qu'on est sur
ces enjeux de compétences vraiment qu'on
mette le paquet et ce qu'on ne voit pas
beaucoup puisque nous avons besoin des
mêmes métiers pour un certain nombre
d'enjeux dans la défense dans l'énergie
il y a des métiers qui sont similaires
et dans les compétences là vont être
véritablement en tension pour revenir ce
que disait monsieur il a raison il a
raison nous avons besoin de parler
beaucoup plus des enjeux démocratiques
autour de la défense parce que
évidemment que les sommes absolument
extraordinaires qui sont proposés là au
vote peuvent être
effrayante pour nos concitoyens et je le
comprends parfaitement parce que
moi-même je défends premier budget je
préférais que ce soit l'éducation où je
préférais qu'on n'est pas besoin que ce
soit l'éducation je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a
un enjeu démocratique à parler beaucoup
plus de la défense parce qu'aujourd'hui
on l'a vu certaines menaces impact
directement le déroulement des élections
impact directement nos vies quotidiennes
et les décisions que nous prenons donc
nous avons besoin effectivement d'une
défense forte mais bien employée ben on
va s'arrêter là merci pour ce mot de
conclusion La Défense est un jeu
démocratique merci à vous d'être venu
débattre sur LCP vous restez avec moi
François Henry desérables dans une
dizaine de minutes elle est partie pris
de nos affranchis ce soir l'économie
avec Thomas l'estavel pourquoi les
startups licencie dans notre pays et
puis on verra aussi avec Richard Berny
son regard européen il va nous parler
aujourd'hui d'une déclaration de
oursela vanderline qui est passé un peu
inaperçu hier à Kiev enfin dans Bourbon
Express ce soir cette bataille du 8 juin
qui se prépare sur les retraites mais
d'abord on part en Iran avec vous sur le
papier c'est un pari insensé que vous
vous êtes lancé vous rendre en touriste
au pays des Molas pour raconter la
société
en pleine révolte révolte contre le
régime et ça donne un très beau livre je
le disais l'usure d'un monde chez
Gallimard et il s'en a fallu d'un cheveu
pour que vous ne finissiez en prison
regardez c'est dans l'invitation de
Stéphanie Despierre et on en parle juste
après
si on vous invite François Henri des
érables c'est pour parler de votre
voyage au pays des mots là fin 2022 vous
avez sillonné l'Iran secoué par la
révolte de la rue et alors que plus
aucun français n’y met les pieds
François-Henri des érables après avoir
grandi à Amiens jouer au hockey sur
glace à haut niveau vous devenez
écrivain en 2015 vous publiez Evariste
premier grand succès en 2021 vous
décrochez le Grand Prix de l'Académie
française aujourd'hui dans l'usure d'un
monde vous racontez vos 42 jours d'un
voyage très risqué sur les traces de
Nicolas Bouvier l'auteur de l'usage du
monde votre récit aussi entre le
pèlerinage littéraire dans les pas du
Dieu des écrivains voyageurs et la
chronique d'un pays en effervescence où
les filles brûlent leur voile
vous comptez vos rencontres avec cette
jeunesse d'Iran notamment votre balade
d'un soir avec nilufar une jeune femme
qui a décidé de vous faire écouter le
merveilleux écho de Téhéran et là elle
commence à crier femme liberté à crier
Marc badictator mort au dictateur et
il y a quelqu'un qui ouvre sa fenêtre au
troisième étage et qui crie aussi et
puis il y a quelqu'un qui passe en
voiture qui baisse sa vitre et qui crie
mort dictateur et puis après on entend
quelqu'un dans la rue d'à côté qui écrit
morodictateur et c'est comme ça que
commence les manifestations en Iran
les manifestations ont commencé en
septembre 2022 après la mort de Macha
Amini arrêté torturé par la police des
mœurs à cause d'un voile trop léger
durant plus de trois mois la
contestation ne s'est souffle pas malgré
la terrine répression la peur était pour
le peuple iranien une compagne de chaque
instant depuis la mort de Macha Amini la
peur était mise en sourdine elle
s'effaçait au profit du courage
cette question du courage irrigue tout
votre livre au-delà du tragique du
moment votre ouvrage est un bon récit de
voyage souvent drôle après ces
pérégrinations vous dites que vous
n'êtes plus le même alors François Henri
des érables en quoi ce voyage vous
a-t-il changé
réponse vous savez il y a une définition
que folkner de donner de la littérature
il disait que écrire c'est comme craquer
une allumette dans la nuit au milieu
d'une forêt et alors vous voyez combien
il y a de l'obscurité partout il dit que
la littérature ça ne sert pas à y voir
plus clair mais à mesurer l'épaisseur de
l'ombre et bien je crois que le voyage
c'est pareil on ne voyage pas pour se
rincer l'oeil de nouveaux paysages on
voyage pour en revenir avec des yeux
différents après pour revenir avec des
yeux différents et je termine juste pour
pour en revenir avec un regard plus
aiguisé un regard justement accoutumé à
l'ombre à l'épaisseur de l'ombre
c'est-à-dire au réel dans tout ce qu'il
a de plus complexe voilà en quoi et
sinon on fait pas un voyage sinon c'est
du tourisme et pourtant ce voyage en
Iran dans les pas de Nicolas Bouvier ce
grand écrivain voyageur il remonte bien
avant la mort de Massa Amini vous
projetiez de le faire et puis il y a eu
la pandémie vous l'avez reporté et quand
vous partez finalement et bien c'est
devenu pratiquement impossible de se
rendre en Iran pour un étranger c'est
extrêmement dangereux seuls les
journalistes étrangers sur place et bien
sont en prison c'est très clair et vous
prenez quand même l'avion est-ce que
vous avez mesuré vraiment les risques ou
est-ce qu'il y a une part d'inconscience
dans ce voyage là les deux sans doute
son voyage était prévu de très longues
dates je vous les suivre l'itinéraire de
Nicolas Bouvier dans l'usage du monde
les publier en 1963 donc pour le tronçon
iranien de ta brise au Baluchistan donc
il traverse absolument tout l'Iran et
évidemment je n'ai pas pu le faire et
lorsque
j'ai
ajourné mon voyage et puis il y a eu la
mort de Marsa mini et là c'est posé la
question de savoir si je partais ou non
et j'ai décidé de partir quand même
parce que précisément parce qu'il n'y
avait quasiment aucun journaliste sur
place parce que les journalistes
n'étaient plus autorisés à entrer en
Iran parce que les journalistes iraniens
étaient arrêtés il y a eu plus de 70
journalistes iraniens arrêtaient depuis
la mort de mars à mini il y en a
aujourd'hui encore 25 qui sont sous les
verrous l'Iran et 177e 1980 pays pour ce
qui concerne la liberté de la presse
d'après le rapport de Reporters sans
frontières donc j'ai le coup de fil que
vous recevez je connaissais les risques
encourus le cador c'est ma pelle alors
que je suis dans l'avion il est trop
tard mais je le savais je le savais et
j'ai eu de la chance de passer entre les
mailles du film en même temps je crois
que les risques encourus je voudrais pas
paraître trop fanfaron parce que les
risques encourus sont bien moindres que
ceux des journalistes qui vont en
Ukraine je ne risquais pas de me prendre
un obus comme ce journaliste qui est
logiquement des CDI quand vous arrivez à
Téhéran vous tombez sur un bassidy vous
ne savez pas qui il est il est
extrêmement curieux les bassidy c'est la
police des mœurs des Gardiens de la
révolution c'est la hantise des Iraniens
parce qu'ils sont infiltrés partout
ouais bah si je dis ce sont des
miliciens qui sont en civils et c'est ça
peut être le chauffeur de taxi le patron
du restaurant le type qui vous
qui fait le pain et qui vous le serre le
matin donc ça peut ça on ne sait pas qui
ils sont pas on ne sait pas toujours qui
ils sont ils sont en civil et
ils ont pour mission de combattre la vie
c'est de promouvoir la vertu en gros si
on traduit ça ça veut dire
surveiller les citoyens et réprimer les
manifestations et lorsque j'arrive à
l'auberge adéan il y a un jeune homme
très sympa qui me propose de partager
son plat de spaghettis bolognaise il
était près de minuit alors j'accepte
comment ça me posait des questions et
puis je vois la fille de l'accueil qui
me regarde avec un regard insistant et
au départ je me dis tiens j'ai dû
utiliser du taper dans l'oeil et un
moment le type se lève et elle vient me
voir et elle me donne un glisse un mot
dans la main et lorsque je le lime
c'était marqué attention ce type est
sans doute un agent du gouvernement ce
qui vous frappe d'emblée à Téhéran ce
sont toutes ces jeunes femmes dans les
rues cheveux au vent vous envoyez devant
le palais de justice dans le bazar sur
les pelouses vous avez même fini
écrivez-vous pas arrêtez de les compter
la moitié des jeunes filles de moins de
30 ans n'a plus de voile en Iran
aujourd'hui et ça le pouvoir l'ampleur
de la du mouvement en fait et du
soulèvement est tel que le pouvoir n'y
peut plus rien moi je qui est vraiment
que c'était un épi phénomène lorsque
j'arrive début novembre 2022 je pensais
que quelques femmes bravées
cette obligation du port du voile et
finalement j'arrive à Téhéran et la
première femme que je vois je suis très
étonné presque que que je vois sans
voile et puis je marche sans mettre et
j'envoie une autre et puis 50 mètres et
puis j'envoie une autre et je réalise
très rapidement que plus de la moitié
des filles de 30 ans je précise dans les
grandes villes surtout les villes
étudiantes puisque cette révolte elle a
été initiée par les étudiants ne porte
plus le voile et donc évidemment j'ai
arrêté de les compter mais j'ai vu à
quel point ce mouvement avait pris de
l'ampleur et la police des mœurs
cessait d'arrêter les jeunes filles
puisque elle était complètement
complètement débordée vous faites
beaucoup de rencontres et vous raconter
au fond cette société iranienne qui se
cache derrière des signes des codes pour
se retrouver ces manifestations qui
n'ont absolument rien à voir évidemment
avec les nôtres comment on se reconnaît
quand on veut descendre dans la rue en
Iran bien les manifestations ça n'est
pas comme chez nous il y a une sorte de
déclaration à préfecture d'itinéraire
prédéfinis on se donne rendez-vous à
Bastille puis on marche jusqu'à
République de 14 à 16h c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe
évidemment on n'a pas le droit de
manifester et donc c'est un petit groupe
d'amis en général qui va dans un lieu
près du bazar par exemple
pour pouvoir s'échapper le plus
rapidement possible et ce petit groupe
se met à crier un slogan
négatif
mort au dictateur et alors là on voit ce
qui se passe et parfois rien parfois ça
retombe et puis parfois ça prend c'est à
dire que d'autres gens viennent
s'agréger à ce petit groupe et puis le
sa forme une sorte de de d'attroupement
et puis s'il a tout manque grossi ça
fait une foule et puis très rapidement
la police répressive arrive et là tout
le monde se met à courir parce que la
dernière chose que vous avez envie de
faire en Iran c'est d'aller en prison ce
régime que les Iraniens veulent faire
tomber il est incarné par un homme c'est
la gâteau la ramène liquide suprême
représentant de Dieu sur terre qui défie
et qui détient tous les pouvoirs elle
met pas mal de temps né le phares cette
jeune étudiante qui vous aborde à
Téhéran à vous dire exactement ce
qu'elle pense de lui à oser vous dire
tout le mal qu'elle pense de lui oui
parce que elle ne savait pas à quoi s'en
tenir avec moi j'aurais pu être à ma
City bon très vite elle s'est rendu
compte que je ne parlais pas le persan
ça se voit pas mal que je ne suis pas
iranien on comprend assez vite mais au
début elle y va bien au piano comme
disait les Italiens parce que elle elle
ne sait pas quels sont mes intentions
donc elles les sont et puis finalement
finalement elle tombe le masque et elle
me dit que elle est très impliquée dans
les manifestations en première ligne en
première ligne elle vous dit c'est l'ADN
du régime qui est vicié l'ADN du régime
ça revient qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
oui parce que ce régime est un régime
théocratique ou le religieux prime sur
le politique ou les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle de façon
doivent être approuvées par une
commission qui régentée par le guide
suprême et ce régime théocratique s'est
transformé en régime déjà cryptocratique
puisque il n'accaparent les richesses de
l'Iran et en régime tanatocratique
c'est-à-dire qui règne par la mort et
par la peur des mises à mort les
Iraniens la peur n'a pas changé de camp
quoi qu'on en dit ça c'est faux
complètement c'est-à-dire que peut-être
que l'ayatollah ramené peut-être que le
guide suprême est pris de de frissons
lorsqu'ils se glisse dans les draps de
son lit et lorsqu'ils sont aux rues de
Téhéran ou disparent ou de Chiraz qui
s'embrassent mais les manifestants qui
descendent dans ces rues ont peur et non
pas peur de mourir ils ont peur d'être
arrêtés ils ont peur d'être torturés
parce qu'on pratique la torture à grande
échelle ils ont peur d'être condamnés
pour inimitié à l'égard de Dieu ou
corruption sur terre qui sont des motifs
d'inculpation assez large pour y à peu
près ce que l'on veut c'est à dire que
si vous brûlez une poubelle lors d'une
manifestation vous pouvez être condamner
à mort c'est arrivé et ils ont peur
d'être pendus à l'aube au bout d'une
grue sans même que l'on dit à leur
famille quand ils vont être exécutés et
ils ont peur d'être enterré la nuit
en l'absence de leur famille voilà voilà
pas peur de mourir non elle a peur de la
prison plus que tout oui
et bien ce que je disais la torture est
pratique à grande échelle le viol des
femmes latence qu'ils appellent la
torsion blanche c'est à dire qu'on vous
met sous des néons aveuglants 24 heures
sur 24 dans une cellule minuscule et
puis bon il y a toutes les formes de
torture imaginable que que les tous les
raffinements de torture que peuvent
inventer les hommes alors il y a une
nylophary il y a aussi firouzet qui vous
emmène sur le mont saufé pour poster une
vidéo d'elle criant mort au dictateur
elle a pas son téléphone elle a plus de
batterie
c'est vous qui allez la tourner cette
vidéo ouais elle me demande de prendre
la vidéo d'elle criances ses slogans
cryant femme vie liberté criant au
dictateur et je prends la vidéo et en
redescendant elle me dit elle aussi que
elle est c'est une fervente opposante du
régime qu'elle aussi n'a pas peur de
mourir mais qu'elle a peur de la prison
et elle me dit comment elle s'y prépare
elle s'y prépare en apprenant des poèmes
alors je lui demande comment les poèmes
vont l'aider à surmonter la prison il me
dit bah voilà on pourrait me priver de
manière thé on pourrait me priver de
mettre dignité on pourrait me torturer
on pourrait le premier de tout ce que
j'ai connu voilà il y a une petite chose
qu'on ne pourra jamais me prendre même
si on me met à l'isolement ou même si on
m'enterre dans une cellule avec des
dizaines d'autres ce sont les poèmes que
je connais par dizaines et dont je me
réciterai les Verts en attendant soit la
mort soit la liberté et c'est vrai que
lorsque vous entendez ça dans la bouche
d'une fille de 18 de 19 de 20 ans que
vous avez presque le double de son âge
que vous savez que vous n'avez pas le
même courage et bien la moindre des
choses que vous pouvez faire lorsque
vous êtes écrivain c'est dans témoigner
et ce livre finalement je ne suis que le
greffier
du du courage du peuple iranien de la
jeunesse iranienne de ces hommes de ces
femmes
la littérature aussi je vous rassure
cette plus qu'un greffier vous êtes un
écrivain il y a des femmes il y a des
hommes aussi
Amir qui sort de son service militaire
qui porte une viscérale du régime c'est
sans doute celui qui est le plus qui a
perdu la foi après avoir assisté à une
lapidation de femmes il faut répéter une
femme enterrée à mi-poitine qui se fait
tuer par des jets de pierre d'homme au
visage on peut pas tout tout raconter
vous allez aussi contre certains
préjugés non tous les Iraniens sont pas
anti-américains par exemple ouais ça
c'était une surprise pour moi alors ils
sont contre le gouvernement américain
ils ont souvent de bonnes raisons d'être
contre mais ils sont pas du tout ils
sont ils n'ont absolument rien contre le
peuple américain et d'ailleurs la
plupart après l'anglais en regardant
friends ou les Simpson porte des baskets
Nike et des casquettes New York Yankees
et sogav évidemment de de films
d'Hollywood l'usure d'un monde c'est
évidemment le monde des Molas personne
ne sait ce qui va se passer mais il y a
cette phrase derrière chaque personne
qui meurt 1000 autres coeur oui ça c'est
un des slogans qu'on peut entendre dans
les rues lors des manifestations
l'usure d'un monde ce monde c'est celui
de la République islamique qui réprime
dans le sang les aspirations de son
peuple et qui est un régime qui en
réalité est déjà mort qui est comme
comme un arbre mort qui pourrit sur pied
et chaque slogan chaque voix qui s'élève
chaque manifestation est un petit coup
de hache dans ce bois mort et la
question reste à savoir quand il finira
par tomber allez c'est-à-dire chez
Gallimard une traversée de l'Iran un
français en Iran c'est absolument
passionnant c'est aussi un témoignage
précieux parce qu'il est très difficile
de savoir ce qui s'y passe et puis voilà
on laisse le lecteur découvrir comment
vous avez pu rentrer à Paris Dardar ça a
été moi une vous avez eu très très chaud
vous restez avec moi François Henri des
érables c'est l'heure à présent des
partis pris de nos affranchis ils vont
vous faire réagir sans doute on les
accueille tout de suite
bonjour et Richard Werly le regard
européen de notre ami franco-suisse du
quotidien biblique Thomas l'estavel pour
l'économie bienvenue à vous deux
préparez vos cartes blanches parce qu'on
commence par Bourbon Express l'histoire
du jour à l'Assemblée nous est racontée
comme chaque soir par Elsa Montana bon
soirée Elsa bonsoir alors l'histoire que
je vais vous raconter c'est plutôt un
épisode un épisode de la série la
réforme des retraites à l'Assemblée je
vous rappelle on en a à peu près à 175
épisodes et parmi les personnages un peu
secondaires mais qui deviennent
principaux le groupe liotte liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire ils
ont déposé on en a parlé une proposition
de loi pour abroger la réforme elle
devrait être examinée le 8 juin prochain
et regardez d'ici là et bien ils
entretiennent un peu le feuilleton
regardez ces images d'André Lafont
aujourd'hui elles ont reçu Sophie Binet
la secrétaire général de la CGT
évidemment elle soutient leur initiative
puisqu'il s'agit et bien de mettre à bas
cette réforme
la CGT elle échange avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires à l'exception du
rassemblement national donc c'est pas
une nouveauté pour nous de ressembler
des des parlementaires qu'ils soient de
gauche ou de droite ou des centristes et
là il y a un objectif commun qui est
clair à savoir abroger cette réforme des
retraites qui est injustifiée
économiquement et très violentes
socialement alors ce petit groupe le
groupe liotte exactement il veut se
placer un peu en médiateur en fait pour
qui parle à tout le monde et qui offre
une sortie de crise au gouvernement
nous organiserons nous accueillerons les
organisations patronales ces prochains
jours nous travaillons avec tout le
monde le dialogue c'est la recette de la
réussite c'est ce qui se fait pas plus
haut de l'État au plus haut niveau de
l'État c'est ce que vous nous voulons
faire ici au Parlement
alors justement ce petit groupe liotte
dont tout le monde parle il tape sur les
nerfs franchement du gouvernement et de
la majorité j'imagine oui il faut dire
qu'à la base c'est un petit groupe
technique avec des élus Corse des
centristes des socialistes qui ont voulu
s'éloigner de la nupaise et au début le
gouvernement comptait dessus pour faire
la point pour trouver des majorités et
bien il se transforme en première
opposant au gouvernement en pointe sur
cette réforme des retraites évidemment
ça énerve et on ironise dans la majorité
de voir et bien décentristes s'allier
avec la CGT
Sophie Binet de la CGT au milieu du
groupe liotte qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire
je trouve légitime qu'un groupe
parlementaire auditionne des
syndicalistes en revanche ce qui
surprend beaucoup plus c'est que le
Président Monsieur pencher soutenait
madame Pécresse il y a moins d'un an
madame Pécresse qui défendait la
retraite à 65 ans donc voir Monsieur
pencher et la représentante de la CGT un
an après je dois dire que c'est assez
savoureux ça démontre qu'au fond par
exemple Charles de Courson qui nous fait
des grandes leçons sur les finances
publiques à longueur de journée à la
tribune de l'Assemblée nationale est
prêt à rogner toutes ses convictions
pour faire des petits coups politiques
la réalité est tout autre ça pétoche
sévère dans la majorité avec ce texte de
loi du 8 juin oui ça donne des sueurs
même si quand on leur pose la question
pour l'instant ils disent on garde la
tête froide écoutez est-ce que ça
inquiète la majorité cette journée du 8
juin imaginons un vote ici à l'Assemblée
pour abroger votre réforme
de dormir donc on prend les sujets pour
les autres et les difficultés sont là
pour être traitées ce qui est très
important c'est que la loi sur les
retraites s'applique à partir du 1er
septembre et c'est ce qui se passera
l'iode ou paliote alors je vais
contredire un petit peu Eric verte parce
que je pense que ça empêche en tout cas
certains de dormir dans la majorité on
commence à réfléchir à toutes les
stratégies possibles pour éviter le vote
de cette proposition de loi pour
certains il faut carrément empêcher
qu'elle soit recevable dans l'hémicycle
ce serait au titre de l'article 40 l'IR
recevabilité financière mais il faudra
passer et bien par dessus le président
de la commission des finances qui a un
insoumis Éric Coquerel d'autres
envisagent une forme d'obstruction plus
ou moins assumée ça peut être des longs
monologues de ministres ça peut être des
dizaines d'amendements ça peut être
aussi et bien le fait de faire durer les
débats on le sait qu'à minuit pour une
niche et bien les débats s'arrêtent il y
a aussi des outils à la disposition du
gouvernement comme le vote bloqué bref
la question c'est aller au vote ou ne
pas aller au vote et un élu bien le
choix cornélien dans lequel se trouve le
gouvernement tout à l'heure la stratégie
n'est pas encore tranchée dans les deux
cas elle n'est pas bonne bon merci
beaucoup vous avez défilé vous contre
les retraites oui donc vous allez
regarder ce qui va se voter ou pas voter
le 8 juin
qui m'a qui m'a gêné surtout la FAGE je
trouve que ça manquait de panache s'il
avait envie de faire voter ça justement
il y a pas eu de vote peut-être qui en
aura le 8 juin allez on enchaîne avec
avec vous Richard je le disais la
présidente de la Commission européenne
était à Kieff hier pour la Journée de
l'Europe et elle a fait une annonce qui
passait un peu sous les radars elle a
dit que les 27 pourraient c'est du
conditionnel sanctionner les entreprises
et même les États comme la Chine qui
contournent les aides non qui
contournent les sanctions à la Russie
expliquez-nous ça est-ce que ça va être
possible alors effectivement c'est
encore loin d'être gagné mais c'est un
projet qui a été présenté par la
Commission européenne le vendredi 5 mai
et cursula vendent dans les hyènes a
présenté à volonymer Zelinski à qui elle
va alors de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit un
peu de temps de vers ce que font les
États-Unis vous savez c'est très discuté
très contesté les États-Unis ont des SAN
extra-territoriale c'est-à-dire des
mesures qui leur permettent de s'en
prendre
utilise le dollar dans ces transactions
alors dès lors qu'une entreprise
commerce avec des pays entre guillemets
paria pour Washington comme l'Iran ou la
Corée du Nord alors il faut faire un peu
d'explication du côté européen depuis le
24 février 2022 c'est-à-dire la Saurus
contre l'Ukraine les 27 pays lieu ont
adopté à l'unanimité ça c'est important
de le savoir 10 paquets de sanctions
contre la Russie un seul but affaiblir
l'économie russe sauf que l'efficacité
de ces sanctions est loin d'être
optimale d'abord parce que la Russie
c'est une puissance industrielle c'est
un géant doté de ressources en minerais
en hydrocarbures mais aussi parce que
ces sanctions sont contournées des pays
comme l'Azerbaïdjan le Kazakhstan
l'Arménie sont devenus des contourneurs
en chef il permettent aux Russes de
s'approvisionner et je ne parle même pas
vous l'avez dit de pays comme la Chine
ou comme la Turquie qui est pourtant
membre de l'OTAN donc ça veut dire que
l'Union européenne pourrait s'en prendre
à des entreprises chinoises turques
demain alors attention contrairement à
Washington et ça c'est important
Bruxelles ne prétend pas imposer sa loi
économique au pays qui ont choisi et
c'est leur droit il y en a de nombreux
dans le sud de continuer de commercer
avec Moscou mais elle peut en revanche
sur la foi d'information ciblées rendre
la vie difficile à des entités qui
profitent de la zone grise c'est à dire
des firmes qui viennent en Europe qui
achètent des composants dont la Russie a
besoin officiellement pour les vendre
dans un autre pays mais en fait qui les
revendent à Moscou avec un gros profit
c'est ça que le projet de réglement
communautaire veut arrêter avec comme
arme simplement l'interdiction d'accéder
au marché unique de quand même 450
millions de consommateurs ou des
pénalités financières alors pour le
moment sur la table il y a un onzième
paquet de sanctions qui va bientôt être
examiné mais ce que je retiens et ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que bruxelles
veut montrer ses muscles c'est en soit
une bonne nouvelle parce que si l'Europe
prétend être une puissance elle doit
agir comme tel il lui faut un gros
marteau vous suivez ça pour nous vous
nous direz quand est-ce qu'on est tous
d'accord pour pour y aller avec le gros
marteau Thomas les startups licencie
surprise pourquoi alors effectivement
Myriam avec le retournement des marché
financiers la roue est en train de
tourner pour la fameuse French Tech qui
montre un visage beaucoup moins cool que
d'habitude alors on a eu de nombreuses
annonces de licenciement ces derniers
jours ces dernières semaines je vous en
liste quelques unes insec une société
innovante qui produit de l'alimentation
à base d'insectes bac market que vous
connaissez peut-être qu'il y a une place
de marché pour les smartphones
reconditionnés Miro qui est une jeune
pousse qui est censée avoir trouvé un
procédé révolutionnaire pour retoucher
les photos de manière automatique mais
on n'a pas encore totalement la preuve
de ça ou encore la plateforme de cours
en ligne openclassroom qui s'est séparé
de 25% de ses effectifs mauvaise
nouvelle aussi pour le gouvernement
j'imagine alors effectivement parce que
c'est un peu la marque de fabrique du
candidat Macron et le président français
c'est directement inspiré de l'État
d'Israël la fameuse start-up nation
depuis 6 ans l'exécutif soutient un fond
les jeunes pousses au point qui Emmanuel
Macron mais aussi Bruno Le Maire pousse
des cocorico sur Twitter à chaque levée
de fond record leur conviction c'est que
ces jeunes pousses très agiles peuvent
disrupter l'économie c'est leur grand
mot et améliorer notre quotidien et à la
limite pas envie d'y croire quand on
regarde des applis bien pratiques comme
Lydia doctolib ou blablacar alors
pourquoi ces difficultés à quoi elles
sont dûes alors en fait on vient de
vivre une décennie faste les banques
centrales ont laissé l'argent cool à
flot les investisseurs se sont bousculés
pour injecter des fonds dans des
startups de peur de passer à côté du
futur Google ou Amazon européen et même
les entreprises mal gérées finalement
parvenaient à trouver des financements
mais avec le retournement actuel et la
hausse des taux les investisseurs sont
devenus beaucoup plus prudents quitte à
lâcher les startups qui faisaient
illusion mais n'avaient pas vraiment de
perspective économique vous connaissez
peut-être ce fameux adage de Warren
Buffett c'est quand la mer se retire
qu'on voit ceux qui se baignent nu donc
c'est pas si cool c'est ça les startups
finalement pas si cool effectivement
alors il faut savoir que ces
entrepreneurs qui ont en général autour
de 30 ans ont très peu d'expérience en
management certains sont impulsifs
persuadés d'être visionnaires et font
peu de cas du droit du travail et la
devise de la French tech c'est un peu
fake it u make it fait semblant d'y
arriver jusqu'à ce que peut-être un jour
tu fasses vraiment le la démonstration
de ton concept j'ai écrit récemment une
enquête sur la start-up e-commerce que
je vous invite à lire la direction a
perdu plusieurs procès aux prud'hommes
mais aussi au tribunal de commerce pour
des impayés auprès de fournisseurs la
disruption pourquoi pas mais il faut
respecter la loi je pense que le Next
forty qui est lundi des 40 startups les
plus prometteuses doit être repensé pour
intégrer des critères éthiques la
start-up nation ok mais pas le Far West
merci beaucoup Thomas vous pourriez
écrire vous sur la start-up nation cet
univers là mais il y a un écrivain qui
est que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle
Nicolas Mathieu qui l'a très bien fait
un peu dans son dernier roman Connemara
qui vient de sortir c'est chouette de le
citer voilà magnifique livre également
on s'arrête là merci les amis Merci à
VOUS Elsa à très vite l'usure d'un monde
clin d'oeil évidemment au grand voyage
de Nicolas Bouvier ça s'appelait l'usage
du monde et là c'est votre traversée en
Iran que vous a raconté chez Gallimard
très belle soirée documentaire qui
commence maintenant avec Jean-Pierre
Gratien bonsoir et à demain
[Musique]